قفزه هائله للاستثمارات الصينيه في الدول
الواقعه على خريطه طريق الحرير او ما يعرف
باسم مبادره الحزام والطريق لتسجل اعلى
مستوى منذ عام 2019
147 دوله تلقت استثمارات صينيه بنحو ثلاثه
33 مليار دولار في عام 2022 وحده بزياده
63% عن العام السابق وفق بيانات جمعتها
جامعه فودن في شنغهاي اضخم الاستثمارات
كانت مشروعا مشتركا بين مرسيدس بنز وشركه
الصينيه لتاسيس مصنع مشترك لبطاريات
السيارات الكهربائيه في هنغاريا هنغاريا
اذا في المرتبه الاولى بفضل هذا المشروع
بنحو سبعه مليارات مليون دولار فما هي
الدوله التي تاتي في المرتبه الثانيه انها
السعوديه بحجم استثمارات وصل الى خمسه
مليارات وستمائه مليون دولار وفي المرتبه
الثالثه تاتي سنغافوره بمليارين ونصف
المليار دولار السعوديه هي ايضا اكبر محطه
للاستثمارات الصينيه في قطاع الطاقه على
الاطلاق بنحو خمسه مليارات مليون دولار في
20 22 واكبر هذه الاستثمارات الشراكه في
شريكه انابيب الغاز التابعه رامبو
بالاضافه الى مشاريع اخرى للطاقه الشمسيه
وطاقه الرياح منذ عام 2013 وصلت القيمه
التراكميه للاستثمارات المرتبطه بمبادره
الحزام والطريق الى
962 مليار دولار من ضمنها عقود بناء
وتشييد بنحو 500 مليارا السعوديه كانت في
المركز السادس في حجم هذه الاستثمارات
التراكميه حتى عام 2021
لكنها قفزت الى المرتبه الثالثه في 20 22
لتثبت موقعها كاحدى اهم الشركاء
الاستثماريين والتجاريين للعملاق الصيني
ومن اهم الركائز لمبادره الحزام والطريق